MILLENNIAL WEALTH:
We’ve all heard it.
The idea that Millennials are worse off than
any generation before them.
59% of Millennials can’t afford a $1000
emergency expense.
Most millennials can’t afford a home and
many are living with their parents.
Nearly 75% of millennials are living paycheck
to paycheck yet 70% of them plan to leave
their jobs, and on and on and on.
This widespread belief paints millennials
as all being broke, lazy, and downright financially
illiterate.
And that all of this is thanks to the boomers
in government and the 2008 financial crisis
that permanently destroyed the economy for
younger generations.
This is the mainstream narrative but it’s
also complete and utter boloney.
Every single statistic that you see on those
headlines are cherry picked to push a narrative.
Consider, for example, the statistic that
when boomers were in their early 30s, they
controlled 20% of the national wealth but
when millennials were in their early 30s,
they only controlled 3.5% of the national
wealth.
This seems like a massive discrepancy and
it is but what most of these studies fail
to mention is the other discrepancies that
easily explain this like demographics.
When boomers were growing up, the US population
was over a 100 million less.
As such, boomers made up for a lot more of
the population than millennials did.
In fact, when you account for this one discrepancy,
the wealth discrepancy not only goes away
but it actually inverts.
I kid you not.
Millennials, on a per capita basis, are actually
slightly wealthier than boomers were at the
same age.
But how could that be?
Aren’t all millennials broke bums living
with their parents?
Well, the truth is that there's a whole nother
group of millennials that are never mentioned
that are richer than any generation before
them.
And I’m not talking about some sort of elite
top 0.1%.
I’m talking about the 35% who have net worths
over a $100,000, the 18% who have net worths
over a $250,000, the 9% who have net worths
over $500,000, and the 3% who are already
millionaires.
Keep in mind, millennials are predominantly
in their 30s right now.
So, it’s safe to say that a large portion
of this 35% will end up as millionaires, multi
millionaires, and deca millionaires.
Now of course, being a millionaire is already
not the same and it wont be the same in 30
years but it’s also a far cry from the narrative
that portrays Millennials solely as financially
struggling losers that are still reliant on
their parents.
The reality is that a large portion of millennials
are actually way richer than you think.
So, join me as we take a look at how this
narrative came to be and discover the truth
about millennial wealth.
IMPOSTER SYNDROME:
Alright, so if millennials are actually doing
just as well as previous generations on a
per captia basis, why do they get such a bad
rep?
Is it just a vocal minority or a media bias
or is their more to it?
Well, I think we can get a better idea when
we take a look at the wealthiest people from
each generation.
The average net worth of millennials who consider
themselves wealthy is $531,000.
On average, millennials needed $100,000 more
than Gen Xers to feel wealthy.
The only generation that needed more money
than millennials to feel wealthy was Boomers
who on average needed $692,000.
But wait a minute, that means that Millennials
have lower expectations than Boomers but aren’t
even able to achieve these lower expectations
because of the crony economy right?
Well actually no because you have to consider
that they’re in completely different stages
of life.
Boomers are predominantly in their 60s meaning
that they’re context is retirement.
This means that Boomers on average think that
$692,000 is enough for retirement as a whole.
Meanwhile, millennials are wanting $531,000
as 30 year olds with 30 more years in the
workforce.
And taking a look at their retirement expectations,
this all makes sense.
On average, millennials are wanting $1.8 million
for retirement or nearly triple what Boomers
are looking for.
Even high inflation and rising living costs
don’t account for that massive disparity
in expectations but you know what does?
Perception.
Wealth is a rather subjective topic.
$2.5 million might be middle class in San
Francisco but in Nebraska, that would be quite
wealthy.
A significant portion of the perception that
Millennials are financially challenged stems
from this subjectivity.
In general, Millennials who are objectively
well-off may not consider themselves as such,
reinforcing the notion of Millennials' financial
struggles.
This notion is less about their actual financial
well-being and more about their ambitious
aspirations.
Again, let me reiterate.
Millennials don’t even think half of a million
is enough to be considered wealthy while boomers
think that $700,000 is wealthy enough to straight
up retire.
But how does such a massive discrepancy in
wealth expectations manifest between generations.
Well, the answer is easy: social media.
Various studies have found that millennials
approach wealth from a comparative basis while
boomers tend to approach wealth from an objective
basis.
For instance, a Boomer might evaluate their
financial status based on expenses: groceries,
taxes, insurance premiums, and so on.
If they can comfortably cover these expenses
for a prolonged period without active income,
they tend to classify themselves as wealthy.
Millennials, on the other hand, don’t define
wealth based on sustainability.
In fact, sustainability has nothing do with
their equation.
Rather, they define wealth based on what their
richest friends can do.
Being able to go on the same vacations, live
in the same luxury buildings, eat out at the
same restaurants, and so on.
In fact, 47% of millennials compare their
lives to their peers on social media while
only 13% of boomers compare their lives to
their social circles.
This explains why millennials have such a
bad financial rep despite doing just as well
as previous generations.
The reality is that 50% of millennials are
actually just broke while the other 50% are
actually pretty well off but they would never
describe themselves as such because their
expectations are multiple times higher than
any previous generation.
Thus, the entire generation is frequently
misrepresented as financially disadvantaged
which isn’t true.
But something that is true about millennials
is the raging wealth divide.
WEALTH DIVIDE:
The
media often frames the wealth divide as a
conflict between the top 1% and the rest of
society.
However, the reality is more nuanced: it's
a struggle between the upper 50% and the lower
50, and I think this graph really showcases
this phenomenon.
The top 50% have net worths anywhere between
$46,000 and $3 million which again is pretty
good.
If we look at the left side of this graph
though, it’s gets ugly real quickly.
A net worth of $0 almost puts you in the 20th
percentile meaning that nearly 1 in 5 millennials
have a negative net worth.
So, the middle class is indeed disappearing
but not in the way that is often portrayed.
Not everyone is becoming broke.
The top half and especially the top quarter
are thriving in the new economy while the
bottom half and especially the bottom quarter
are getting annihilated.
But how did we get here?
Well, people often point the finger at politics
and capitalism, but I think the answer has
more to do with 3 social trends starting with
the 2008 financial crisis.
Discussions surrounding the recession typically
revolve around its impact on the job market,
economy, and opportunities.
But the most important item that the recession
destroyed, atleast for millennials, was the
investing spirit.
It’s kind of a meme that millennials are
the degenerates gambling on options and AMC
and NFTs and all of that crap, but that’s
actually such a small portion of millennials.
The vast majority of millennials are actually
extremely conservative when it comes to investments.
In fact, they prefer to just hoard cash.
65% of millennial wealth is held in cash,
the highest of any generation, and much of
the rest is in real estate.
Only a mere 15% is actually invested in stocks
which is really bad when you consider that
boomers have 24% invested stocks even though
they’re supposed to be risk averse ones.
The 2008 financial crisis gave millennials
investing PTSD like no other generation.
In fact, 57% of millennials admit that the
crisis still influences their investing choices
while the same is only true with 39% of Gen
Xers and just 13% of boomers.
Given that investing is the key to not just
retirement but financial freedom in general
especially in times of high inflation, it’s
no wonder why there’s such a wealth divide
amongst millennials.
There’s the half that invests and the half
that doesn’t.
Many millennials would argue that they just
don’t have enough money to invest and this
is often true as well because many of them
are stuck in mountains of college debt.
Of course, the skyrocketing price of tuition
very much plays a role here, but I believe
the crisis is more closely linked to the relevance
of education.
Millennials were strongly urged to pursue
higher education, which was often touted as
the key to securing good jobs and success.
As such, 38% of millennials ended up getting
a degree while only 32% of gen Xers and 15%
of boomers have a degree.
However, this largely backfired as a lot of
millennials ended up getting degrees just
because they were told to do so resulting
in a bunch of expensive degrees that have
no value in the job market.
As such, many of these millennials would end
up getting jobs that didn’t even need a
degree or paid more for a degree making it
even harder to pay off the debt.
If they didn’t end up in one of these jobs,
it’s more than likely that they ended up
in one of the new age gig economy jobs which
is even worse.
We’re talking food delivery, ridesharing,
freelancers, etc.
On paper, these jobs actually have pretty
good salaries but what they don’t have is
any benefits which makes them far worse.
A police officer or teacher may only make
$60k, but they get another $60k worth of benefits
in the form of health insurance, retirement
benefits, paid time off, set work hours, a
better tax situation, etc.
An uber driver making $60k on the other hand
is closer to earning minimum wage.
So, I think much of the millennial wealth
divide can be explained by an aversion to
investing, irrelevant degrees associated with
massive college debt, and the modern gig economy.
But, honestly, I think one factor trumps all
of these.
TECH WEALTH:
I think almost the entirety of the millennial
wealth divide can be explained by one factor
and one factor alone: technology.
Millennials who have embraced tech are experiencing
remarkable success, while those who have not
find themselves struggling.
And I’m not just talking about coders and
project managers.
I’m talking about people who leveraged tech
vs people who did not.
You can see this in any profession.
The wealthiest lawyers are the one’s serving
tech companies, not the local judge.
The wealthiest teachers are the ones selling
courses online, not the ones in public schools
or even Harvard professors.
The wealthiest accountants are the ones working
at tech companies, not the ones working at
the IRS.
The wealthiest doctors are the ones on social
media, not even the ones doing neuro surgery.
While this inclination was already taking
shape during the boomer and Gen X generations,
it has escalated to an unprecedented degree
amongst millennials.
Before 2000, non tech people, in inflation
adjusted terms were making $40-60,000 while
tech people were making $70-90,000.
Some might cross $100,000 but that was pretty
much it.
Today, it’s still hard for non tech people
to reach $70 or $90,000 but tech people are
able to reach $200, $500, $1 million per year
by the time they’re 30 or 40.
The disparity between non tech and tech people
is no longer 40% or 50%, it is straight up
a magnitude.
And it’s no wonder why, the leverage, scale,
and efficiency that’s possible with tech
is incomparable to any traditional job.
As such, their earnings potential is far higher.
Also, remember all of those shortfalls that
we were previously discussing?
Well, those are automatically solved by tech.
Take stock investing for example.
If you’re in tech, you’re either going
to be forced to take stock compensation whether
you like it or you’re earning so much that
even if you’re conservative with your stock
investing, it adds up to a substantial investment.
Also, if your degree aligns with the tech
sector, the ROI of college becomes astronomical
and paying back the debt becomes no problem
at all.
In the realm of the gig economy, while certain
gigs like being an Uber driver might be less
appealing, other tech-driven opportunities
such as becoming a YouTuber, entering e-commerce,
owning Airbnb rentals, or being a remote tech
worker is extraordinarily favorable.
The bottomline is that the modern economy
works for tech people and people who are 1
to 2 degrees of separation away from tech.
For everyone else, it sucks.
And this is preciesly what’s manifesting
in millennial wealth.
50% are doing way better than you think but
the other 50% are doing way worse than you
think and that is the true state of Millennials.
AI is no doubt the next frontier but I don’t
think it’ll replace as many jobs as people
think.
Check out this video to learn more.